uh well get your peanuts here the Las
Vegas ballpark is hosting a job fair
this weekend and you may just be perfect
for some of those positions that they're
hiring uh maybe you could help Candace
out a little bit yeah she's live over
the ballpark with what it takes to get
some of these jobs Candace I will you're
hard at work there I think that that's
going the right way man that is a timed
event there Candace you know that in
between Innings morning Candace I feel
like I'm doing a pretty pretty good job
at this you guys I mean this is hard
work that you have to do and I'm doing
it in style as Chuck Johnson tell me
something that you know you probably
wouldn't be wearing out here but there
are a lot of positions like this one
here at the Ballpark they're about eight
of these but so many more right chuck oh
a boatload more vote lower and a lot of
fun ones I hear a great fun one day I
think about 200 we're looking for so you
know be on the field handling the
grounds crew working with the mascots
working on game day with our games and
stuff for uh the games working
concession bartending weight service
food Runners all that stuff it's all
available at the Ballpark oh
I love here and get a
gray and this and you make it you make
it not too difficult they come down to
the fair they bring their resume right
so what are you guys looking for yeah
we're looking for energetic people that
you know have a willingness to work
outside and be part of the ballpark yeah
it's a lot of games 75 home games plus a
bunch of extra games and then and
special events that we do out here so we
have a lot of opportunities that come
out and really have a good time working
out this beautiful place yeah and it
absolutely is beautiful we got to see
the sun coming up here is quite a place
to work you guys and it's different age
ranges that you're accepting as well
yeah we really I mean 16 16 is probably
about the the minimum you know we also
have a few positions yes you know for a
14 year old you know I love that so yeah
yeah wide ranging yeah yeah and it's a
seasonal job but you guys are paying
fairly well I like that yeah it's a
little bit you know it's uh elevated
above minimum wage you're looking at
right around 15 it can be higher for
some more specialty jobs so it's not too
bad yeah I love it thank you so much
chuck for chatting with us this morning
you have been a pleasure even though you
did beat me a little bit early earlier
you guys missed that but that's okay you
maybe didn't want to see that anyway of
course you can find out more details on
our website eight newsnow.com the career
fair like I mentioned it's on Saturday
from 10 to 3. bring your resumes guys
it's gonna be a wonderful morning and
afternoon yeah live from the Las Vegas
ballpark I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now